y
i
[Música]
en francia miles de ciudadanos salieron
nuevamente a las calles para protestar
contra la ley sanitaria que está siendo
debatida en el senado la legislación
incluye la obligatoriedad de un
documento digital para permitir la
entrada a algunos establecimientos
públicos y la vacunación obligatoria de
profesionales de la salud
[Música]
en brasil miles de personas se tomaron
las calles de 400 ciudades para exigir
la destitución del presidente ya ha ido
evolucionado con su gestión de la
pandemia de cobain 19 que ya deja más de
548 mil muertos organizaciones sociales
denuncian negligencia y corrupción por
parte del gobierno
en hungría miles de ciudadanos se
unieron a la marcha anual del orgullo en
budapest en apoyo al colectivo lgtb de
pumas y en contra de la polémica ley que
limita la enseñanza sobre la
homosexualidad y la transexualidad en la
escuela del país según el gobierno la
medida busca combatir la pedofilia
actualizamos la información de américa
latina y del mundo aquí entras 24 mi
nombre es liliana valencia hablábamos de
francia porque miles de ciudadanos se
tomaron las calles en varias ciudades
del país para protestar contra la ley
sanitaria la legislación incluye medidas
como el pase sanitario un documento
digital que verifica si la persona ya
está vacunada cuenta con una prueba
negativa reciente o acaba de recuperarse
del coi 19 el pase ya es exigido para
entrar a ciertos establecimientos
públicos este fin de semana el senado
debate la posibilidad de ampliar los
lugares donde se exigirá el documento a
partir de agosto y la obligatoriedad de
la vacunación para ciertos profesionales
de la salud pero un sector de la
ciudadanía considera que la medida va en
contra de las libertades individuales
esperamos poder meterle algo de presión
al gobierno y decirle que hay muchísimos
franceses cada vez más y más que
rechazan el pase sanitario que nos
quieren imponer y que simplemente
quieren su libertad y que no queremos
esta vigilancia generalizada ni una
sociedad en la que los trabajadores de
los pares o de los restaurantes estén
obligados a vigilar
nosotros lo que queremos es vivir libres
es lo único que pedimos miles de
personas salieron este sábado a las
calles de 400 ciudades de brasil para
pedir la destitución del presidente ya y
de el bolsón aro a quien de aprovechar
entre otras cosas su gestión de la
pandemia de ccoo y 19 la popularidad del
mandatario se encuentra en su peor
momento desde que llegó al poder
fuera bolsonaro este grito vuelve a
resonar en las calles de brasil donde
miles de personas salieron a exigir un
juicio político contra el mandatario
entre otras cosas los manifestantes
condenan al presidente por su discurso a
favor de la explotación de las áreas
protegidas de la amazonía y su gestión
de la pandemia en un país donde la tasa
de mortalidad por kobe 19 es de 260
personas por cada 1000 habitantes ya hay
medio millón de muertos en brasil esto
tiene que parar fuera el genocidio es la
cuarta jornada de manifestaciones
convocada por partidos políticos
opositores sindicatos y movimientos
sociales contra bolsonaro que además
está siendo investigado por la fiscalía
por irregularidades en las negociaciones
de vacuna anti cobit
es muy importante que todos los que se
sientan ofendidos y oprimidos por este
gobierno salgan a la calle
porque tenemos que luchar por el retorno
de la democracia
[Música]
bolsonaro vive su momento más difícil
desde su toma de funciones en 2019 un
sondeo realizado por la encuestadora
brasileña xp y pp del 5 al 7 de julio
mostró que el apoyo de los votantes al
presidente cayó hasta 14 puntos por
detrás de su mayor rival de cara a las
elecciones de octubre 2022 el ex
presidente de izquierda luiz inácio lula
da silva el 30 de junio la posición
presentó ante la cámara de diputados un
súper pedido del pitch men con un
centenar de peticiones de destitución y
más de 20 acusaciones contra el
presidente
o inicio en nicaragua el proceso de
verificación ciudadana del padrón
electoral liderado por el consejo
supremo electoral de cara a los comicios
generales del próximo 7 de noviembre
allí el presidente daniel ortega buscará
un cuarto mandato y una tercera
reelección consecutiva los ciudadanos
deben acudir a partir de hoy y verificar
si su documento de identidad está activo
en el padrón electoral y en qué lugar
deberán votar éstos mientras un séptimo
aspirante a la presidencia fue arrestado
se trata del derechista noel vidaurre
quien fue puesto bajo arresto
domiciliario
en hungría miles de ciudadanos se
unieron a la marcha anual del orgullo en
budapest este sábado para apoyar al
colectivo lgtb
y protestar contra una polémica ley que
limita la enseñanza sobre la
homosexualidad y temáticas transgénero
en las escuelas del país según el
gobierno húngaro la medida busca
combatir la pedofilia pero para muchos
ésta también restringe aún más los
derechos del colectivo el informe es de
amal benotman
la comunidad lgbt de hungría tomó las
calles para celebrar el día del orgullo
pero esta vez se suma una nueva consigna
luchar el motivo el gobierno del país
quiero organizar un referendo para
mostrar el apoyo del público a una ley
que según organizaciones de derechos
humanos así como la unión europea
discrimina a las personas lgbti
viktor orbán el primer ministro ha
anunciado un referéndum sobre la
protección de la infancia y las
preguntas son muy transfóbicas y o
mejoras de ahí la enorme indignación de
la sociedad húngara muchas personas
están enfadadas y quieren mostrar su
apoyo a la comunidad lgtb
más por eso pensamos que será una marcha
del orgullo histórica probablemente la
más grande de la historia del país el
gobierno sostiene que la ley aprobada el
mes pasado por el parlamento tiene como
objetivo proteger a los niños
no es un derecho humano que los
activistas lgtb
estén en las escuelas no su derecho
educar a los niños sobre
estilo de vida y estilos de vida son
para los adultos y los niños serán
libres de hacer lo que quieran cuando
sean adultos pero mientras están en la
escuela tenemos que protegerlos
entre otras cosas esta ley prohíbe la
representación de la homosexualidad y
tema transgénero en las escuelas algo
que para muchos se restringe aún más los
derechos del colectivo lgtb de un
referendo constará de cinco preguntas
una por ejemplo apunta si los ciudadanos
aceptarían charlas sobre orientaciones
sexuales en las escuelas y otra los
interpelará sobre su posición ante las
terapias de cambio de sexo a menores
orbán instó a votar no a cada una de las
preguntas se elevó a 125 la cifra de
víctimas mortales por las inundaciones y
deslaves causados por las lluvias
torrenciales que azotan india desde hace
una semana más de 90 personas fueron
rescatadas en las zonas más afectadas
por las aguas el estado de maharashtra
se registraron las más fuertes
precipitaciones en los últimos 40 años
carolina los al león nos informan
buscan sobrevivientes entre las casas
sumergidas los equipos de rescate en
indias se encuentran en una carrera
contra el tiempo para evacuar a miles de
personas afectadas por las torrenciales
lluvias que continúan y vacían represas
para evitar más desbordamientos uno de
los estados más afectados por la
emergencia es maharashtra en el
occidente del país en varias localidades
la gente busca a sus familiares e
intenta recuperar lo que quedó de sus
pertenencias entre el lodo y los
escombros no puedo ver nada aquí mi casa
mi gente mis vecinos no puedo encontrar
a nadie especialmente en zonas rurales
los deslaves y los desbordamientos del
río destruyeron docenas de edificios y
casas a su paso por lo que fue necesario
el envío de fuerzas especiales de
socorro para ayudar a miles de familias
damnificadas
y ahí no hay nada no tenemos ropa comida
ni siquiera ropa interior ni agua para
bañarnos son tres días que no hemos
comido tenemos hambre las inundaciones y
deslaves son comunes en india durante la
temporada del monzón entre junio y
septiembre sin embargo las lluvias que
actualmente golpean maharashtra son las
más fuertes en cuatro décadas según los
registros históricos de la región
vamos con información del continente
africano porque el parlamento de sierra
leona votó el viernes a favor de abolir
la pena de muerte un castigo que será
sustituido por la cadena perpetua o una
pena mínima de 30 años de cárcel el país
de asia occidental no había realizado
ninguna ejecución desde 1998 porque
desde entonces la pena capital se ha
estado consultando el último paso para
la definitiva abolición de esta ley
depende del presidente julius maravillo
quien celebró la decisión del
legislativo de sus redes sociales
finalizamos hablando de los juegos
olímpicos de tokio en los que américa
latina empezó pisando fuerte con el
ecuador haciendo historia de la mano del
ciclista richard capaz que consiguió la
medalla de oro en ciclismo de ruta
escuchamos su reacción
para mí algo muy grande sobre todo que
va a quedar como digo marcado en la
historia
historia de mi país a falta de seis
kilómetros sabíamos que había un
kilómetro y medio que era muy duro
que con 24 puntos
[Música]